nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
direction rossignano en Italie cette
station balnéaire de Toscane a des airs
de cartes postal pourtant elle est le
théâtre d'une napre bataille entre le
géant de la chimie le groupe belge
Solvay et les défenseurs de
l'environnement Louise malnois bonjour
on vous retrouve en duplex de Rome vous
êtes notre correspondante cette image
qu'on vient de voir de plage digne des
Maldives et trompeuses même si elle
attire les touristes car elle est le
fruit en fait d'une pollution
oui alors ça saute aux yeux puis c'est
pas désagréable à regarder il faut dire
que la couleur de l'eau la couleur du
sable sont sublimées par des résidus
liés aux procédés de fabrication de
bicarbonate de soude alors ce sont
essentiellement des rejets de calcaire
présentés comme inoffensif mais ça fait
plus de 100 ans que ça dure et
l'accumulation n'est pas sans
conséquence alors en 1999 déjà rosiniano
a été classé parmi les 15 sites les plus
pollués d'Italie par le programme pour
l'environnement des Nations Unies et
depuis alors ce classement n'a pas été
actualisé mais l'usine préoccupe
toujours
Solvay ne l'ignore pas il dit s'employer
à tout faire pour réduire son impact sur
l'environnement donc nous c'est ce qu'on
a essayé de mesurer non sans mal et on a
constaté que cette longue activité a
bien laissé des traces durable dans
l'environnement alors on va découvrir ça
dans le reportage que vous avez tourné
donc en Toscane avec Natalia Mendoza et
Lorenza Penza
[Musique]
sur plus de 4 km
mer bleue turquoise
sable d'un blanc étincelant
nous sommes à une centaine de kilomètres
à l'ouest de Florence sur la côte
toscane
avec ce sable blanc
un décor qui n'a rien de naturel
elle est caractéristique même si elle
est un peu artificielle si cette plage
est aussi blanche on sait que c'est dû
au rejet de l'usine de bicarbonate de
soude
au-delà de ce panneau accès interdit la
baignade est limitée car nous sommes aux
abords d'un site industriel qui
déversent ces rejets directement sur la
plage
depuis 110 ans cette usine propriété
d'un groupe de chimie belge fabrique ici
du carbonate du bicarbonate de soude et
de la soude caustique pour les
industries agroalimentaires
pharmaceutiques et la production de
verre
en moyenne chaque année
146000 tonnes de déchets sont recrachés
sur la plage
dont des métaux lourds 500 tonnes de
mercure se sont accumulés sur le rivage
d'après un rapport des Nations Unies
je monte et tu me passes tes affaires
après
Mario Savino et passionné d'immersion
sous-marine
cette instructeur de plongée se désole
de l'extinction de la faune et de la
flore sur ce rivage méditerranéen
le couteau c'est fondamental parce
qu'ici on manque de visibilité
parfois on tombe sur des filets
abandonnés il faut pouvoir les couper et
se frayer un chemin en évitant les
dangers
cet enfant du pays vient rarement ici
car il sait qu'il n'y a presque rien à
voir
[Musique]
pour le démontrer il descend 10 mètres
sous la surface de l'eau
[Musique]
aucun signe de vie au sol le paysage est
désolé
tout est recouvert par une couche
blanche de sédiment
[Musique]
une absence le marque particulièrement
une algue qui pousse proche des côtes
car elle a besoin de lumière
et là avec la transparence de l'eau qui
est altérée dans cette zone le cycle
reproductif de la posidonie a été
complètement abimée
en plus des rejets de sédiments jetés en
mer qui s'accumulent au fond et font
tout se focus
voilà à quoi ressemble les fonds marins
des environs quand les courants ne
draguent pas les rejets de l'usine
caractéristiques de la Méditerranée il
faut faire au moins 5 km et demi de la
zone de rejet aller à bonne distance de
l'usine
cette plante typique du bassin
méditerranéen joue un rôle majeur celui
d'abri pour la reproduction d'un grand
nombre d'espèces
ce qu'observe ce passionnait de plongée
a été confirmé par l'Agence régionale de
protection de l'environnement dans un de
ces rapports elle constate
la prairie de posidonie face à roseniano
a subi une régression vers le large
l'usine de rossignano a durablement
altéré son environnement
[Musique]
longtemps surnommé Mama Solvay le site
industriel a employé des milliers de
personnes à rosiano
la ville de 16000 habitants ces
structuré avec son développement au
point d'en prendre le nom
ici le chimiste belge s'affiche partout
dans les rues sur les façades des écoles
du stade municipal et même du centre
culturel
ce jour-là de nombreuses habitants s'y
pressent même le maire promeut
événement rare Solvay ouvre ses portes
nous avons profité de l'occasion pour
visiter le site d'ordinaire interdit au
public
la soude caustique comme vous voyez est
utilisé dans les détergents pour le
nettoyage
les employés sont mobilisés pour faire
de la pédagogie et rassurer
ce ne sont que des solides inertes
naturelles qui dérive d'un procédé fait
à partir de matières premières qui sont
transformés en poudre
en pratique ils sont inertes
le site industriel emploi aujourd'hui
1600 personnes
à sa tête le français Nicolas du Genetet
20 ans de carrière dans l'entreprise
nous avons obtenu un rat entretien avec
lui et lui avons demandé la composition
précise des rejets qui s'accumulent sur
la côte depuis plus d'un siècle ce sont
des solides qui sont autorisés inertes
pourtant plusieurs études soulignent la
présence de métaux lourdsorbée par les
poissons des environs si vous êtes si
vous êtes d'accord par rapport donc à
l'interview d'aujourd'hui on est sur un
sujet associé aux Portes Ouvertes
donc si vous avez des questions
techniques spécifiques sur un document
évidemment que je n'ai pas lu avant si
vous êtes d'accord je vous propose je
vous propose de l'envoyer directement au
service de communication et on vous fera
une réponse
l'entreprise nous a renvoyé à son site
internet elle précise respecter tous les
standards italiens et européens et se
conformer à tous les contrôles
[Musique]
pourtant le site a plusieurs fois été
pointé du doigt par le parquet de
Livourne et des associations de
protection de l'environnement par deux
fois des dysfonctionnements ont généré
une dispersion d'azote d'ammoniaque
anéantissant toute la faune environnante
[Musique]
des accusations toujours contestées par
le groupe chimique
[Musique]
ce n'est pas la seule pollution qui
inquiète les riverains Massimiliano
Posarelli connaît parfaitement l'usine
de rosiniano il habite à quelques
centaines de mètres
[Musique]
alors ici on voit le site de fabrication
de la soude
conserver
[Musique]
son père Romano posaélie il a passé
l'essentiel de sa carrière
il est mort d'un cancer fulgurant en
c'est qu'il respirait mal il se
déplaçait avec peine
on nous a dit que c'était une tumeur au
poumons et qu'elle était due à la
cigarette
parce que je n'ai jamais vu mon père
fumé
Massimiliano en est convaincu son père a
été exposé à l'amiante pendant des
années c'est cela qui aurait provoqué
son cancer de la plèvre
ce document relate toutes les tâches
réalisées par mon père à l'usine
et pourtant à la fin il est écrit que
mon père n'a jamais été au contact de
l'amiante
Massimiliano a démontré le contraire au
terme de 10 ans de procédure judiciaire
en juin 2021 le tribunal de Livourne a
condamné Solvé à l'indemnité
l'entreprise réfute sa responsabilité et
a fait appel
[Musique]
le cas de son père ne serait pas isolé
Massimiliano nous présente ce document
listant toutes les pathologies
développées par des employés de
l'entreprise qu'il s'est procuré au fil
de ses investigations
[Musique]
par exemple celui-là est mort d'une
tumeur de la plèvre il était assigné à
la plomberie comme mon père
la prévalence de cancer de la plèvre à
rossignano et trois fois supérieur à
celle des autres villes de Toscane une
maladie liée à l'amiante qui se
manifeste des années après l'exposition
solvait La sûr il n'y a plus d'amiante
sur le site de rosiniano pourtant le
problème de santé publique ne s'arrête
pas là un médecin s'est penché sur les
causes de décès dans la commune
le docteur Claudio marabouti et
cardiologue
il a mené une enquête statistique sur 10
ans comparant le nombre et les causes de
décès à Rosignano au reste de la région
avec cette analyse statistique qui les
ressorti qu'on est fait il existe ici
des maladies pour lesquelles on meurt
plus que dans le reste de la Toscane
d'une manière statistique significative
en moyenne chaque mois on déplore ici
deux morts de plus qu'ailleurs en
Toscane cancer de la plèvre maladies
cardiaque et neurodégénérative sont les
plus représentés
certains d'entre eux s'accumulent dans
l'organisme par exemple le mercure entre
mais ne ressort jamais donc même si on
ingère de toutes petites quantités qui
semblent inoffensive mais qu'on les
ingère tous les jours cela a des
conséquences biologiques au fil des
années le mercure peut provoquer des
maladies neurodégénératives comme
Alzheimer le docteur Claudio marabouti
demande depuis 3 ans une étude
approfondie pour croiser les données sur
les émissions de polluants dans la
commune et la répartition des maladies
en 1999 déjà l'Organisation des Nations
Unies classait l'usine de rossiniano
Solvay comme l'un des 15 sites les plus
pollués d'Italie aujourd'hui encore
l'ONU s'inquiète de la pollution dans
cette commune
j'encourage le gouvernement italien à
s'assurer que l'industrie utilise des
technologies et des méthodes de
production qui n'affectent pas la santé
des citoyens à entamer une stratégie de
gestion des déchets et à mettre en place
une économie circulaire à commencer par
la réduction des déchets dans un rapport
présenté à la session de septembre
dernier à Genève le Rapporteur spécial
sur les droits de l'homme et de
l'environnement soulignent le risque de
greenwashing soit la crainte
d'engagement écologique de façade sans
effet réel
le rejet de ce que l'entreprise appelle
des solides inertes contient cependant
du mercure et autres métaux lourds qui
se retrouvent sur la côte de la Toscane
et ce qui explique la couleur de ses
plages autour de rossignano et c'est
quelque chose de préoccupant
vient d'obtenir le renouvellement de son
autorisation de rejeter ses déchets en
mer à hauteur de 250 000 tonnes par an
pendant 12 ans un recours a été déposé
devant le tribunal administratif sous la
pression l'entreprise a annoncé envisagé
cesser cette activité à horizon 2050
en attendant la commune laisse libre
accès à la quasi-totalité de ses plages
féeriques qui enivre les touristes du
monde entier
et on retrouve Louise malnoy qui a
réalisé ce reportage whisky à Rome avec
nous comment est accueilli cette annonce
de réduction des déversements de
l'entreprise par ses opposants Louise
alors elle est diversement appréciée en
tout cas elle a convaincu bluebel c'est
un fonds d'investissement britannique
activiste qui avec cette annonce est
retirée de la procédure présentée devant
le tribunal administratif de Toscane
mais on parle d'une fin d'activité et
d'une fin des rejets en mer à horizon
2050 ça allait encore 27 ans d'activités
et c'est bien trop pour au moins trois
associations et 19 citoyens qui
maintiennent leur recours formulé devant
le tribunal administratif de Toscane
pour demander l'annulation de
l'autorisation des livrets à Solvay de
poursuivre ces déversements en mer alors
déjà il faut savoir qu'en 2003 Solvay
c'était engagé à réduire le volume de
ses déchets passant de 200000 tonnes à
60 000 tonnes par an cela devait se
faire en quatre ans mais finalement ça
ne s'est pas traduit dans les faits
quels sont les engagements pris par
l'entreprise pour cesser les rejets
alors pour l'instant il s'agit d'un
cadre fixé par Solvay il s'agit déjà
d'un investissement de 15 millions
d'euros pour moderniser les technologies
utilisées quant au calendrier solvez
vice de réduire déjà de 20% le volume de
ces rochers d'ici 7 ans puis de 40 % à
horizon 2040 mais quand elle a technique
c'est encore un petit peu flou alors
nous on a demandé des précisions à
l'entreprise on a demandé si on pouvait
venir découvrir ces nouvelles
installations pour les filmer mais ça
nous a été refusé alors quant à la
méthode on nous a annoncé qu'il
s'agissait de réduire la granulométrie
du calcaire utilisé mais sans plus de
précision en tout cas les autorités
veillent au grain puisque Solvay doit
présenter tous les six mois l'avancée du
projet pour contrôler le plan qui vise à
remplir ses objectifs et puis quand au
matériau qui sont déjà déversés sur les
côtes pour l'instant il ne s'agit pas de
les retirer
Louise malnois correspondante de France
24 en Italie merci Louise c'est la fin
de ce magazine merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
reporter sur France 24
[Musique]